only a few elements can be permanent
magnets iron is one copper is not but if
you pass an electric current through any
metal it becomes a magnet an
electromagnet but how does this work
well strangely enough it's a consequence
of special relativity special relativity
is the fact that in our universe length
and time aren't absolute they're
perceived differently by observers
moving relative to each other hence
relativity for example if you measure
carefully enough you'll find that time
passes slower for observers moving
relative to you hey Derek when did you
last shave six hours ago actually it was
5 hours 59 minutes and 59 point nine
nine nine nine nine nine nine nine nine
nine nine seconds and moving objects are
also contracted in their direction of
motion you're looking slim only in your
frame of reference so when an object is
moving relative to you it actually takes
up less space than when it's not moving
and even though this effect is obviously
way tinier than we've shown length
contraction is what makes an
electromagnet work picture a copper wire
it consists of positive metal ions
swimming in a sea of free negative
electrons now the number of protons is
equal to the number of negative
electrons so overall the wire is neutral
so if there were a positive charge
positively charged cat nearby it would
experience no force from the wire at all
and even if there were a current in the
wire the electrons would just be
drifting in one direction but the
density of positive and negative charges
would still be the same and so the wire
would be neutral so no force on the
kitty but what if the cat starts moving
imagine for simplicity that the cat is
moving in the same direction as the
electrons with the same velocity well
now in my frame of reference the wire is
still neutral and so there should be no
force on the cat but consider the same
situation in her frame of reference in
the cat's frame of reference the
positive charges in the wire are moving
so according to special relativity their
separation will be ever so slightly
contracted also from this perspective
the electrons aren't moving so they'll
be more spread out than before remember
objects take up more space when they're
not moving
than when they are these two changes
together mean there's a higher density
of positive charges in the wire so it's
no longer neutral it's positively
charged which means that the positively
charged cat will feel a repulsive
electric force from the wire but in my
frame of reference this seems mysterious
there's no force on a stationary charged
cat but a moving cat is somehow repelled
from this neutral wire how do you
account for that force well we say it is
the magnetic force and that's mainly
because a wire with current in it
deflects nearby magnets so really what
this experiment shows is that a magnetic
field is just an electric field viewed
from a different frame of reference in
the cat's frame of reference it is
repelled from the wire due to the
electric field created by the excess
positive charges produced by the effects
of length contraction in my frame of
reference the cat is repelled from a
neutral wire due to the magnetic field
created by the current flowing in the
wire so whether you see it as an
electric or a magnetic field just
depends on your frame of reference but
in either case the results are the same
so an electromagnet is an everyday
example of special relativity in action
now that might seem crazy since
electrons drift through wires at about
point zero zero zero zero zero zero zero
zero zero one percent the speed of light
so how can special relativity have
anything to do with it well the truth is
there are enough electrons in a wire and
the electric interaction is so amazingly
strong that even the miniscule effects
of length contraction can produce
significant charge imbalances that
produce a noticeable force so special
relativity explains electromagnets but
what about permanent magnets yeah I mean
there can't be electrical currents
flowing around inside lumps of rock can
there click here to go to MIT physics
where we'll explore magnetite compasses
and all the wizardry of permanent
magnets
you